you forget now the broad pack is this
wonderfully iconic term with spoken with
affection and reverence for this moment
in pop culture and for a certain
generation you know I and other members
of brat pack are the Avatar of their
youth you know and so it's looked at
with his rose-colored memories but that
was not the case at the the brat package
came out the term was coined in 1985 in
a New York Magazine article about all
these young actors and called them the
brat pack anyway so it was a really
negative pejorative thing and we
hated it and it we thought who wants a
who wants to be called a brat who wants
to be in a pack I did a hugely it
adversely affected our careers because
we were now yeah we were now perceived
as this you know all you ever want in
life is to be seen right see me in the
instant the brat pack label came out it
was like
or something we were 180 you know it
turned hard and we were members of the
Brad pack and I was unseen